All right.
So we spent a long time reviewing general equilibrium and we've now switched to
finance.
And your hopefully going to see that the principles of finance emerge very
quickly from the principles of general equilibrium.
So that although it seems it was a long interlude,
we've actually learned a lot about the financial economy.
So we,
I'm going to continue with the example that we started with last time.
So we have a financial economy.
So no financial economy.
What is a financial economy on this top board,
the financial economies defined by lots of people in the economy and their
utilities.
So that's here we have for simplicity,
two kinds of people,
a and B with utilities given by the log x one plus one f log two,
et Cetera.
It's also people know today what their endowments are and they have some idea of
what they're going to be tomorrow.
So here you know their labor power today and they're going to be able to work
again next year.
So the,
uh,
the Labor is a endowments are given a by one,
one for a and one zero for B.
And then they also know that there are two stocks in the economy and they have
to anticipate what the dividends are going to be.
And as Fisher said,
the main value of assets is that they,
they give you something,
they produce something.
In this case they're going to be dividends and Betas producing given end of two
alphas producing dividend of one next period.
And then they,
they own ownership of a shares.
So that's the beginning of the economy.
And we want to define from that equilibrium which involves who,
what are the contemporaneous price is going to be that's Q for contemporaneous,
what are the prices of the stocks going to be and who's going to hold which
portfolio of acids of stocks and who's going to,
who's going to consume what.
And so Fisher said that's a very complicated problem.
You can simplify it by looking at a general equilibrium problem,
which is much shorter describe.
And so the general equilibrium economy is going to be much simpler.
One,
it's going to consist of you a and you be the same as before.
And he hat a one the endowments,
he hat a two and he had B one B two.
Okay.
So we've left out half the variables up there and we define he hat a one equal
to eat a one equal to one.
And he had B one equals e v one equal one,
but he had a two.
This is the fissure insight equals e a two plus.
What a owns of the payoffs of the future.
Dividends.
A Alpha of the f of the
Beta two.
Okay.
So since a owns half of the Alpha stock,
or sorry,
all of the Alpha stock and half of the Beta stock,
his endowment is one for what his or his original thing,
plus what the stock is going to produce.
And after all,
he's the owner.
So he's going to get half of to,
uh,
all of one
plus a half of two,
which is equal to three.
And so I didn't,
I took more space than I thought.
And so similarly,
he hat B two is going to be one plus a half of two,
which equals two.
Okay.
So here,
um,
the endowments or this
and also,
uh,
let's just write it here.
He had a to equal three.
So this,
okay,
so Fisher sad.
We start with a financial equilibrium.
We can switch to the economic equity Librium and solve this problem and having
solved that one,
go back and figure out how to solve this one.
And you remember what the prices were?
They turned out to be few.
One,
I might as well write it up there.
What the prices we had we solved.
We said,
first of all,
Fisher has no theory for the contemporaneous prices.
It's all relative prices.
I'm going to write that relative prices as all we can ever figure out.
You know,
someone might always come along and change dollars to sense.
When I was a little boy and France on vacation,
they suddenly announced that the frank was going to be divided by,
you know,
everything that was 100 francs would now be one.
Frank.
And you know,
they just,
we redefined the currency.
So that might always happen.
So you have to have some theory of money and whether the government's going to
do that to figure out the nominal prices.
So the,
uh,
so contemporaneous prices,
he says,
or one one,
all right.
But having realized that if there are many gardens at time,
one,
he could figure out the relative prices.
But if only one good at time one who's to say whether we're measuring dollars or
Franks or sense,
we'll just call it one.
And the same thing's going to happen next year.
Who knows whether it's dollars or cents or francs.
So we're going to call it one again.
But after that,
he,
he figured everything out.
This turned out to be a price of a third.
This turned out to be a price of two thirds.
And we figured out all the consumption's,
uh,
which I've forgotten,
of course.
But anyway,
they were,
who knows what they were.
Not that it's still important.
Um,
all right,
well I forgot what they were.
Anyway,
he figured out all the consumptions.
I think they were,
uh,
actually I sort of remember them.
Um,
well let's say I don't,
anyway,
we figured out all the consumption's.
Does anyone remember what they were?
Oh,
all right.
I will look them up.
Four thirds to two thirds to,
okay,
so they were four thirds.
Two and two thirds and two a and two thirds and two.
Okay.
So he figured out an equilibrium.
And how did he do it?
Cause he solved over here first he would have saw the,
didn't do this exact problem but he would've solved over here and we would have
found with p one equal to one p two equals a third and sure enough x a one
equals four thirds x a two equals two and x v one equals two thirds and x equals
two.
Okay.
So Fisher said,
start with the financial economy,
figure out what the reduced general equilibrium is,
solve for this equilibrium and go back and figure out what the financial
equilibrium should be.
All right,
so I want to now examine what we've done and we did that at the end of last
class.
You had to do it in a problem set.
Okay.
And you notice that the bay only difference between this and that is the general
equilibrium throws away a lot of irrelevant information.
Cause Fisher said people are rational.
They look through the veil of all the Jibberish of the WHO owns the company and
stuff like that.
And they're just anticipating what the company's going to produce.
They don't really care about whether there's a man running the company or a
woman running a company or whether she's got an Mba from Harvard or from Yale or
none of that's irrelevant.
You know what the business plan is,
all they care about is what's going to actually happen in the end.
So if you think they're going to anticipate that correctly,
you don't need to worry about all the other stuff.
So there's the,
uh,
um,
so looking through the veil,
you can always reduce the financial equity room to a general equilibrium.
Now I want to go back and reexamine all that logic.
Okay.
So what's the first step in what a Fisher did?
And this is the idea.
So of uh,
no arbitrage.
It's a Fisher,
said,
people look through the veil of things,
they understand stuff,
and you can count their understanding to guide your understanding of the
economy.
So if you know that Pi Alpha equals this is a big pie,
Pie Alpha equals a third.
Okay.
So Fisher says,
well,
you don't have to solve for the whole equilibrium to figure out what Pi Beta is,
what,
what's Pi?
Beta B?
We'll Fisher would have said stock Beta always pays off exactly what stock Alpha
pays off.
So if these people are rational,
they're not going to allow for an arbitrage,
then I can allow for.
So arbitrage means there too.
Uh,
assets are two things that are identical.
They have to sell for the same price.
That's no arbitrage.
If they did,
if they sold for a different price,
there'd be an arbitrage and you'd sell the more expensive one and buy the
cheaper one.
And so you'd have accomplished a perfect trade off,
but you'd have gotten the difference of money.
So few.
So since Pi Alpha's one third Pi has to equal two thirds,
hey,
that's the first most important principle of finance.
Um,
that Fisher introduced the idea of no arbitrage and making deductions for no
arbitrage.
So most of the finance is actually being more and more clever about how to do no
Over half of this course is going to be,
let's look at situations where,
you know,
at first glance there doesn't seem to be any arbitrage.
Then you realize if you're clever enough,
uh,
you'll recognize an arbitrage and be able to figure out all the prices without
having to know all the utilities and everything else.
Okay.
So the,
the one of the main goals of finances to explain acid prices,
you can see how no arbitrage is going to help do that because if you knew what
some of the asset prices were,
you could deduce what the rest might be.
Okay?
So that's the first thing Fisher did and he's used this fact and connecting
these two economies.
Okay.
So that's the first thing.
Now that principle can be used over and over again.
So let's suppose that another application of it,
let's suppose that we introduced
a nominal bond,
pay off
what,
$1 in period two.
And suppose as before that Q one equals Q two equals one as we've already
suppose.
Okay.
So can we figure out,
so then by definition the price of this bond
is equal to one over one plus I where I is the nominal interest rate.
Okay.
Why is that?
Because you're going to get a dollar next year.
If the price is less than a dollar this year you're turning something less than
a dollar into something more.
The equal to a dollar.
You're multiplying today's price by one plus I to get tomorrow's price.
Or the rate of return is one plus I taking whatever you put in today and getting
one for side tomorrow.
So what is one plus PSI?
So,
so by no arbitrage we can figure out what one plus I must be.
Okay.
So $1 today can go into three units
of stock Alpha,
okay?
Which goes into three,
uh,
units of x t x two as dividends.
Hey,
which equals $3.
So you take $1 today by buying stock Alpha,
you can get three units of it.
Since it's price is a third
and it's in stock.
Alpha pays one unit of a,
where is it?
One unit of output.
Next period.
You know that $1 today gives you three months of stock Alpha,
which gives you three units of good too is the output.
And at that price,
$1 tomorrow you've anticipated that's $3.
So by buying stock Alpha,
you can put in a dollar and get up $3.
So means that one plus I is equal to three.
Okay?
Which means the interest rate is 200%
okay?
So that's the second thing you could deduce from that.
So notice that by looking at part of the equilibrium here,
we can figure out a lot of the rest of the equilibrium.
So what's another application?
Well,
Fisher said.
Define the real interest rate,
right?
As trader as a,
you know,
number of goods today
goes into number of goods tomorrow.
Okay?
So,
so this will be one plus r equals that,
okay,
the number of goods today and how many goods tomorrow do you get?
So how can you do that?
Well,
$1 today can go into one good today.
One unit of x one
is $1 today,
right?
Because you can tell if you had one apple today,
you could sell it for Q one times one apple,
which is Q one times one,
which is one times one,
which is $1 today,
which you can get three uh,
three shares,
three units of stock Alpha,
which gives you,
um,
three units of x two.
Okay?
So one unit of x one today turns into three units of x two.
So therefore one plus r equals three implies r equals 200%.
So that's the real rate of interest.
So Fisher said it's a,
one of the tricks,
and going from here to here,
it was to say that Fisher realize that people are going to look through all the
jibberish of money and they're going to think about what apples are they giving
up today and what apples are they getting tomorrow?
Then I can to get,
you know,
they're not going to be confused by all the holding of assets in between.
All right,
so let's just make it a little bit more complicated for suppose.
Um,
we started with
Q one equals one Q two equals two.
Now,
I told you that equilibrium Fisher says there's no,
you can't figure out,
there's always a normalization.
Vol Rasa originally had the normalization in one period.
There was all the one period model in general equilibrium in multi period
models,
there's a normalization.
Every period,
every period there's a choice of where you're dealing with dollars or Franks or
certain teams or how many.
And so there's a free normalization.
So let's take Q one equal to one and Q two equal to two.
Well,
what does that mean?
That means that inflation.
Yeah,
one plus,
let's call it growth of money.
Gee,
I,
I've already used for the nominal interest rate.
So one plus g is going to be two over one or just to,
so,
so inflation equals a 200% it equals 100%
100%
okay.
So what's Pi Alpha going to be?
Okay,
I've done my work now and the rest I'm going to just ask you for the rest of the
numbers.
What's Pi Alpha.
So if I resolved meQuilibrium taking Q on equal to one and Q two equal to two,
all that's kind of money stuff.
So it's not going to change what happens over there.
You're going to get the same eco living over there and you're going to go back
to over here.
So what's Pi Alpha going to be?
Okay.
Uh Huh.
Suppose we knew we were in the same real economy.
There's nothing changed about utilities,
Endowments of Gourds,
productivity of the stocks.
All we know is that inflation is going to be higher now.
So what do you think would happen in the new equilibrium?
What's going to happen to the price of stocks today?
Yes.
Price of stock Alpha.
What was it before?
Okay,
so what was it before one?
Yeah,
one,
one third.
So it's still one third.
Okay.
So here we've got,
okay.
This is a big mystery and finance,
you know,
big question and finance and now,
okay,
so you see why it's puzzling.
You didn't get the answer right off,
although she did,
but,
so you just have to think about it a second.
If you really thought that people when they were buying and selling only bought
a stock because they said to themselves,
you know how many apples am I going to get out of this stock?
I don't care about dollars and son teams and Frank's,
I'm not going to eat that.
I'm going to eat the apples and I'm going to,
maybe I'll get the apples and sell them and eat pears instead.
But I care about the,
the goods I'm going to get.
So I looked through all the veil.
I should recognize that the stock,
although it's not going to pay twice as many dollars as it did before.
Okay,
so it's going to pay $2 that's how so and guests to someone said to,
okay,
so how did he get to,
I didn't even realize how he came up with a number two.
He came up with a number two because he said,
well,
the stock is paying one apple tomorrow.
The price of apples is now too,
so it's paying $2 tomorrow.
So maybe it should be worth $2.
It's priced today should be too,
but no,
that isn't how much the stock is worth.
The stock is worth,
you know,
solving for this general lack Librium supply and demand.
And so the stock we already calculated before the stock was a third.
So the price of the stock is going to stay a third because the apples that pays
tomorrow hasn't changed.
Okay.
Still the same one apple.
Now how did we know of a stock was priced at a third before?
Well,
biff.
Okay,
so what was the stock in general?
What's the price of the stock?
Price of the stock.
Okay.
Remember is how did we get it by going from here to here,
we said it's going to equal the price of the stock divided by p one.
Okay.
Now the stock is only paying a certain number of goods.
So the value of the goods today,
okay,
this is going to equal
mmm.
Price of the stock today is going to equal the present value one over one plus r
times.
Um,
it's dividend.
Okay,
well,
the price of this,
so let's just,
I'll write it this way.
The price of the stock is p two times this.
Let's just write this.
Okay.
What would Fisher say?
Fisher would say,
how did we get the price of the stock from going from here to here?
We got the price of the stock by saying,
okay,
um,
we got the price of the stock by saying
the stock pays off one good tomorrow.
Okay,
but one good tomorrow is only worth a third of one good today.
So therefore the value of the stock is only equal to Ufford Times one equals one
third.
Okay,
so assuming [inaudible]
he won equals one.
Okay.
So,
okay,
so in terms of,
that's what Fisher would say.
Assuming p one is one,
you figure out how many units of today's good is it worth?
Okay.
Now if he won isn't one,
then what do you do?
Suppose p one we're five and [inaudible] were he wanted to six let's say.
And P two is to,
then what would you do?
You'd have to say p one times Pi Alpha is equal to d alpha too.
Okay.
So if you,
if you,
uh,
okay,
multiplied all the prices by,
um,
am I putting the p one down to the bottom of the toffee multiplier at all the
prices by three.
Just leave it like this.
We'll say if Pi Alpha equals p Times d alpha took,
if you measured in terms of goods,
that's how you're doing.
Now what would,
so w,
so if you take this,
this is also equal to
one over p one divided by p two.
If p one is one,
assuming p one is one.
Okay?
Times the Alpha two.
Okay.
Which is one over one plus r times GL for two.
So Fisher said,
so here's his famous equation.
Fisher said the way to figure out the value of a stock,
if you solve that problem over here,
so look at its dividends and discount them by the real rate of interest.
One Unit of output tomorrow.
Since the value of a,
an apple tomorrow is only a third is the value of an output today.
Remember the interest rate one plus R,
the real interest rate is equal to the ratio of the two blood.
Okay?
Okay.
So p one over p two is just one plus r one plus R is p one over p two so okay,
I'm not saying anything,
I'm saying I'm making something simple.
The more complicated.
Sorry.
So let's just say it again.
When when we,
we solve that equilibrium over there,
we got,
we figured out that p two is only a third of p one the price.
When people think today,
how much would I give up of apples today to get an apple next year?
They don't think Apple's next year are worth nearly as much as apples this year.
So a third of an they'd only give up a third of an apple this year to get an
apple next year.
P two is the amount you give up today to get an apple next year.
So it's a third.
Another way of saying that if p one is one is that the,
the real interest rate,
the tradeoff between apples tomorrow and apples today.
Just p one of repeat too because one apple today can give you three apples
tomorrow.
So p one of repeat two is three.
Okay.
So one plus R is three.
So the apple tea tomorrow is worth p two times the dividend.
That's just one over one plus r times the dividend.
Okay.
So the,
so the value of a stock is the v the real dividends.
It's paying in the future,
discounted by the real rate of interest.
You're turning tomorrows next year's goods,
finding the equivalent in terms of this as goods.
And
the ratio of those two prices is the real rate of interest.
And so that's how you would get it.
So another way of saying the same thing is you could churn cash next year into
cash this year.
So assuming he won his one,
another way of saying that is one over one plus I Times d alpha,
two times Q to
face.
You take the nominal rate of interest
times the money that's being produced because the nominal rate of interest says,
how do you trade off a dollar today for a dollar in the future?
So a dollar in the future is worth,
you know,
I'll say,
okay,
so a dollar in the future isn't worth usually as much as a dollar today.
So you have to discount it.
So a certain number of dollars in the future is worth less dollars today.
So you take the payoff of dollars in the future,
discounted by the nominal rate of interest,
and you get today's price or you take the real dividends in the future,
discounted by the real rate of interest and you get today's price.
So both those things are an application of the principle of no arbitrage looking
through the veil.
Okay.
So what would the nominal interest rate be in this case?
In this case?
You see,
how did I know the p Alpha was still a third?
Because the real interest rate hasn't changed.
It's still 200% so d alpha two is one and I'm still multiplying by one third,
so I'm still getting a third for the price of Alpha.
Okay.
So that's how she knew that the answer should stay a third cause she knew
nothing wheel had changed in the economy.
Therefore the real interest rate couldn't have changed.
Therefore the price of the stock still had to be the same.
So how could we have used this formula?
We have to know what the nominal interest rate is.
So what is the nominal interest rate?
How much,
if you put in a dollar today,
how much is,
how many dollars can you get out in the future in this new economy where there's
100% inflation?
Yes.
Okay,
so that's right.
Now how did he do that?
Because let's just do it.
You take $1 today,
you at Christ Q one equals one you can buy three units of Alpha still is,
it's price is still a third okay.
And that tells you that you get three units of x two that's the dividend of
three lots of Alpha each.
Each share of Alpha plays one right,
one apple and you get three apples.
But that's equal to three times two because the price has to equal to six $6
tomorrow.
So you've turned $1 into $6 so one plus I equals six over one implies I equals
500% that's exactly what he said.
Okay,
so just say that,
you know,
just more simply the real rate of interest.
One plus r.
This is most famous equation Fisher ever wrote is one plus I divided by one plus
G.
Okay,
so this is called the Fisher equation.
Oh look to he's too famous equations for this.
It's called the Fisher equation.
And this which is called the f.
These two things,
which are the same,
I called the fundamental theorem of asset pricing.
Okay?
So why is this the arm true?
The real rate of interest trades off apples today for apples tomorrow.
All the real rate of interest,
the apples today for apples tomorrow.
So we had one apple giving him three apples.
That's why our was 200%.
Well,
if inflation is 100%,
so this is two.
Okay,
one apple today gives you three apples in the future,
but that means one apple today gives you $1 is one apple today gives you three
apples are $6 in the future.
So that's why,
so you have to take,
um,
so three times two.
So if this is equal to three and inflation's 100%,
so this is equal to two,
then what's the fair rate of interest?
What will the banks give you?
Well,
any banker can take a dollar,
buy a stock,
turned to three units of dividends,
and then sell it for $2 a piece and get $6.
And so a banker can take a dollar and turn to six.
So competition will force the bankers to give you $6 for every $1 you give it
next period.
So the interest rate has to be one plus I equals three times two or six.
So the real rate of interest is the nominal rate of interest divided by
inflation.
Okay?
And so that's one subtle,
but you know,
once you realize it,
obvious implication of thinking people are rational and make sort of simple
calculations,
uh,
looking at the future.
And a consequence of that is the price of assets are you look at the cash that
comes out in the future,
discounted by the nominal interest rate,
or you look at the real goods that come out in the future and discounted by the
real interest rate.
And it's all the same thing.
Okay.
So does anybody know what the inflation is today or what the nominal interest
rates are today?
So I is the nominal interest rate.
The amount of interest you put in the in the bank and what they'll pay you at
the end of a year.
So we're going to next class,
we're going to find out the exact numbers,
but what do you think it is about,
does anyone have any idea?
Take a wild guess as a 10% 5% yup,
usually.
And do you think it's higher or lower than usual nowadays?
It's probably.
Okay,
that's good.
So let's say it's around 2% so that means this is 1.02 and what do you think
phenomenal interest rate is now
one who said that?
That's a good one.
Percent okay.
That's about right.
Okay.
So what is the real rate of interest now?
What?
It's less,
well,
less than one plus r is less than one.
So,
so r one plus R is around point 99 okay.
So the real rate of interest is actually like negative 1% how did that happen?
Do you think?
It's standard to have the real interest rate be under zero.
So why is it under zero?
What's going on now that would make that happen?
Yup.
To
Aha.
The Federal Reserve has cut the interest rate,
the nominal interest rate that it lends that to vary,
you know,
to close to zero,
let's say to 1% on the one year bond.
Tom's zero on the three month thing.
Okay.
And so the reason they're saying they're doing that is to stimulate investment.
That's what they teach you in macro Keynesian stimulate investment.
We're going to find out that that's not the reason they're doing it at all.
The reason the Federal Reserve is cutting the interest rate Donald zero is to
just give money away to the banks.
And why is that?
Well,
when you put your money and deposit it in the bank,
you're getting almost no interest.
So the banks,
the big banks are,
I've got all these deposits and people,
you know,
they don't change what they do.
They just leave their money in the banks getting no interest.
So the banks have the money for free and they can make money with it.
And so they're normally,
they'd have to pay 3% interest or something and that would be expensive for
them.
And they had,
well,
you know,
that expense is a big part of their expenses.
They don't have it anymore.
Okay.
So we're going to come back to that.
What's really going on today,
but that's what's going on.
But anyway,
the point is the nominal interest rate is somehow controlled by the Fed.
That's why we don't have a theory of it.
We're not going to do macro in this course.
So Fisher doesn't have a theory of the nominal interest rate,
you know,
of inflation.
But he does tell you,
given inflation and the nominal inflation in the normal interest rate,
that's determining a real interest rate.
Okay.
And people should look through that.
So now they should say,
this is sort of a Keynesian part.
They should realize that actually an apple today,
you know,
uh,
if you just sort of put in the bank,
you get less than an apple in the future.
So you should spend it and do something with it.
That's the Keynesian idea.
So people,
you know,
why fritter away part of your apple do something with it.
That's why it's supposed to stimulate demand and activity today.
Okay?
So the point is that's how you calculate the real rate of interest and by,
you know,
shockingly,
it's a negative and it's hardly ever a negative,
but it can be negative.
Okay.
There any questions about this?
No arbitrage business.
All right.
So,
um,
okay.
Okay.
So let's do one more uh,
trick here.
Fisher thing.
Suppose that a new,
um,
so let's go back to the equilibrium with Q one.
If you want equal one and Q two equal one.
Suppose,
uh,
suppose China
offered to
when money lenders dollars at a 0% interest,
would that be a great deal?
Okay.
When people rush to do that,
this is the equilibrium we solved over here already.
So it was not a great deal.
Would that upset the equilibrium?
What anyone bothered to take the Chinese deal?
If they lent at 0% interest,
they were offering to do that?
What?
No,
they wouldn't take it.
Okay,
we're back here.
What's the nominal interest rate in this economy?
Yeah,
200% interest.
So if you want to borrow in this economy from another American,
you have to give the guy 200% interest here.
The Chinese are offering to lend you at 0% interest.
So of course.
So yes,
everyone would rush to take the thing and a okay.
And that would have a big effect.
And what the Echo livering was,
if the Chinese were willing to lend money,
it's such a low rate of interest.
Okay,
let's try another question.
Suppose you could turn.
Suppose you invented a technology,
new technology,
new technology churns one unit,
one apple today into two apples tomorrow.
Is this something people would rush to do or not?
Suppose someone inventor figured out how to do that.
Would he rushed to do it?
Could it be used to help the economy?
So let's put it this way,
could this new technology,
new technology
we used to make a parade.
Oh,
improvement.
Everybody better off.
Yup.
Okay.
So that's exactly
the right answer.
The answer is actually you're answering two questions.
I asked two questions.
One is,
could it be used to help the economy make everybody better?
Off,
if a social planner was in charge of things and the Chinese invented this new
technology or some American and Alaska invented this new technology,
you know,
should the government,
uh,
use the technology and couldn't use the technology to make everybody better off
the answer to that is no.
And then the answer to a second question is,
suppose the guy in Alaska discovered himself,
he didn't,
couldn't care less about the Pareto improvement and helping other guys and the
American planners or anything.
He just wanted to make a profit for himself.
Would he make a profit?
The answer is no because the,
you know,
the real prices Fisher would say,
or one and a third.
Okay.
And,
and this would,
uh,
you know,
no matter how you look at it,
the interest rate is 200.
The Re,
you know,
he,
he's losing money cause he's giving something up that's worth one and he's
getting something that's only worth the two thirds.
So He'd be losing money to do it.
He'd lose money.
So we could prove that even.
Okay.
So,
so the answer is no,
that's the first question.
And nobody would do it anyway and fortunately
nobody would choose to do it.
Choose to use it,
use it because it loses money.
Okay,
so those are two separate questions.
You know,
could it be used and would anyone choose any individual choose to do it?
Would it be good for the society when an individual choose to do it?
The is happened to agree here,
so why can't it be used as a prey to improvement?
What's the
proof?
What's the proof of this that it can't be,
the answer is no.
What's the proof?
Well,
the proof is that if it did,
if in the end
and it led to an allocation
x hat,
a one,
let's call it x twilled to lay one x two it'll a two next to it will be one x
two it'll be two
that made everyone better off.
Yeah.
Okay man.
Well we give their old proof then what it means that p one x twiddle a one plus
p two x twiddle eight two is bigger than what he won.
He had a one right?
That's what you have in the Fisher economy.
Plus p two he had a two and similarly he won x twiddle B one plus p two x
twiddle bead to bigger than p one.
He
had the one
plus p to be happy to.
Okay,
so why is that?
Because in this fissure economy,
the general equilibrium,
if this allocation really made a better off than what he's gotten than four
thirds and two,
he would have chosen it and she would be,
she would have chosen her thing if it was better than two thirds and two.
So clearly there must have been too expensive for those two to choose cause they
were rationally choosing the right thing,
given what they could afford.
So then you just add the stuff up
ad and you find that total consumption.
Yeah,
value.
Value.
It's bigger than total endowment value.
Hey,
that's in the Fisher economy.
But we've changed the Fisher economy.
Okay.
Because now we've added this technology which took out away some of the first
good and made it into the second cord.
But that technology is just lost money,
which is bigger than total value.
Okay.
In new technology economy.
All right,
so let me just say this.
And so that's a contradiction because the consumption of this,
however,
the new technology got used in the end,
the total consumption of the people had to be the total of what there was and
what was produced in the economy.
The value after the new technology is introduced in that new economy has only
gone down compared to the Fisher economy and the Fisher economy value of
endowments must have been less than this brilliant new allocation.
And that's a contradiction because there's new allocation has to add up to the
stuff that's there and the new technology economy.
Okay?
So that's how we know that no new technology could possibly make everybody
better off.
And we know trivially that if it loses,
okay,
it may,
it makes everyone better off if and only if it makes a profit.
So if and only if it makes a profit,
can it be used to make everybody better off?
And Amazingly,
in a free market economy,
people are gonna use it if and only if it makes a profit.
So they're gonna use it if and only if it's a good thing for the economy.
So that's the basic laissez faire argument,
that there are new discoveries all the time.
Every other day somebody is thinking of something new.
Are we gonna?
Are we gonna use it?
Should we use it as,
as something we need to read about in the papers and use?
Well,
there are a whole bunch of people,
the discover is themselves.
They're going to talk to their business friends and they're going to say,
you know,
do you want to lend me the money to get this thing going?
And all of them are going to do this profit calculation.
If they decide it loses money,
they're not going to do it.
And thank God for that because it couldn't have helped everybody if they did use
it.
So that's the main lesson of laissez faire.
So let me just put this in perspective a little bit.
In the old Russian economy of the 1930s and forties there was no profit system.
So the central planner had to figure out should a new invention be used or not.
So every time there's a new invention,
a committee had to get together a central planners and decide whether to use it
or not.
And there was a famous guy named overage who was in charge of a lot of that.
He won the Nobel Prize in economics.
He shared it with a Yale economist named coupons.
And so cantor overage told this very amusing story.
He said that there were two central planning bureaus.
One was in charge of allocations and one was in charge of prices.
One had to set the prices,
the other had to set the allocations.
And of course the whole message here is that you have to combine these,
you don't know whether it's worthwhile to change the allocation until you know
whether the new technology is going to make a profit or not.
And here they had the two things separated.
They were telling people what to do before knowing whether they made a profit or
not.
Cause they didn't have prices because they weren't free markets.
But anyway,
so,
okay,
so the bottom line of the Fisher story is that you take this complicated
financial economy,
you reduce it to something very simple that you learn how to do in your freshman
year or your sophomore year.
Solve that.
And you go back to this and you can understand a lot about this economy.
That's something that most people didn't realize at the time and still don't
realize now.
So you ask a typical person if there's inflation,
that means the value of the stock is going to be,
the dividends next year is going to be higher.
Is that going to raise the value of the stock today?
Just like he said?
Yes,
of course.
Cause it makes the price of the dividends higher tomorrow Fisher would say no,
it doesn't change anything.
Wheel on the economy.
If there's more inflation,
there'll be a higher nominal interest rate.
So the discounted by the higher interest rate payoffs of the stock will give you
the same stock prices before.
Okay.
So are there,
so we're going to do a thousand app,
uh,
examples of this,
but are there any questions about this?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Sorry.
I don't know if this is in the way,
by the way.
Okay,
so this is the argument we gave a few classes ago.
I forgot when we said,
how do you know that a final allocation that is a competitive equilibrium is
prayed or efficient and the argument was if you can do better,
that means make everybody better off then they each person,
if you look at the value of what they're getting under the new regime,
it must be more than the value of their endowments.
Otherwise they would've chosen the new regime and nobody chose it.
That means everybody would have had to pay more for this new regime allocation.
Then the value of their endowments.
Okay,
so this is more than that.
For person a and person B's consumption is more than the value of his endowments
is extended endowments and the Fisher thing under this new regime than the value
of his endowments.
You're following that.
Okay.
Then the next step was to add all this up.
Now notice in the file,
however,
the new technology affects the world.
Obviously people can only eat what's being produced.
Everything that's being produced is part of somebodies endowments.
So if the new technology,
you know of Mr a invents the new technology,
he gives up some of his good at time one to get more of the good at time two.
So his endowment has changed,
but he's got a new endowment,
but it's still his endowment.
So whatever the new allocation is,
it has to add up to the new endowment.
Now,
I haven't even bothered to write down the new endowment,
but I know the value of that new endowment,
whatever it is,
is going to be less than the value of the old endowment because the new
technology loses money.
Okay.
So the contradiction is the value of the new endowment after the technology is
used at the old equilibrium prices is lower than the value of the old endowment
at the old equilibrium prices.
But that since it's true for every person in the aggregate,
that's less than the value of this new regime consumption.
And that's a contradiction because the new regime consumption,
that's all this stuff has to equal exactly the total endowments in the economy
to begin with.
And that's the contradiction.
Okay?
So you can't make everybody better off that simple argument,
which as I said,
uh,
my advisor,
Ken Arrow,
another guy at Yale named Gerard Debreu,
both of them were working at the Coles Foundation,
which was part of Yale.
That proof that they gave is most important,
simplest and most important argument and all of economics.
Okay?
So we get as a conclusion that putting it another way that um,
owners,
owners of owners of firms
should
maximized.
Okay.
Share the value of their firms,
the value of the stock market,
value
value of their firms.
And thank God they do.
Because if they find some new way of producing that's going to lose money,
it's gonna make the stock market value go down.
Remember the stock market value is just the same calculation,
the value of all the output they're producing.
If they find some way of losing money and they try to use it,
it'll make their stock market value go down.
That's why they're not going to do it.
And that thank God for that because it'd be a bad thing for society if they did
do it.
Yes.
Knowledge the price.
So let them change might not be true.
I'll change it.
Okay.
It was a very bold question telling me that as a flood proof,
I'm want to commend you for your courage,
um,
as it happens.
However,
uh,
you've asked the same question that somebody asked a class or two,
which is a very good question.
Uh,
so the answer is no,
I shouldn't have changed the prices.
And that's exactly the point of the proof.
So yes,
it's true that after the new technology is introduced,
the prices change,
everything changes.
But we don't have to worry about all that complication.
After all the changes,
there's going to be some final allocation of goods that supposedly makes
everybody better off.
So I can ask the hypothetical question,
would this new allocation to a,
at the old prices be something he could have afforded?
And the answer must be no.
Well,
let me just finish.
So you're,
you're see the answer to your question,
but I'm going to say it out cause a very important question.
So at the,
so the proof is clever precisely because of what your asking you.
You have to do something that you wouldn't have thought of.
You have this new economy and new allocation,
a new prices,
but the proof says,
let's do the hypothetical up thing of looking at the new allocation at the old
prices,
at the old prices.
Peep a couldn't have afforded this new allocation that because if he could have,
he would have bought it because it makes them better off.
So at the old prices,
a couldn't have afforded this new regime allocation similarly be at the old
prices,
couldn't afford this new regime allocation.
Okay,
so at the old prices,
everybody would have to be spending more on the numerous team allocation than
the value of their endowment.
That means that the old prices,
the total and the whole society,
by adding it up of the expenditures on the new regime,
consumption's must be bigger than the total value of the old endowments.
Now,
that was the contradiction.
Why at the old endowments without production,
you couldn't make everybody better off.
We'd already have a contradiction.
Now we add one more step.
We've got this new technology that changed the old equilibrium endowment,
the old endowments.
It changed the old endowments.
But however it changed that we don't have to keep track of how it did it.
It made the value of the total endowments even last than it was before.
So we actually get a worse contradiction than before.
So it was a good question.
So I thank you for the question.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Yes,
yes,
I can raise which board?
Not this one.
Yeah.
Well,
sorry.
Okay.
So the bottom line here is that,
let me just summarize.
We've spent,
you know,
four classes on reviewing standard,
intermediate,
micro and macro.
People never talk about that stuff when they do financial finance courses and
typical courses.
However,
Irving Fisher,
the inventor of half of finance,
that's how he began.
And it's going to turn out now,
especially in light of this last crisis,
that the best way to understand what's going on is to go back to the original
underlying economy.
So Fisher said you can always,
we haven't introduced risk,
by the way,
when that happens,
things are gonna get more complicated.
Fisher couldn't deal with risks.
So without risk,
where everybody's anticipating the dividends in the future,
that means that you can always reduce a financial economy up there to a general
equilibrium which you've been taught before.
You got to this course,
most of you how to solve.
And now that solution to that problem with margin utility and pray to
efficiency,
that tells us an enormous amount about how the stock market and everything
works.
It tells us that the value of every stock is just the discounted real dividends
discounted at the real rate of interest or the discounted nominal payoffs.
Cash flows discounted at the nominal rate of interest.
And it tells us that the real rate of interest is the nominal rate divided by
the rate of inflation.
Okay?
And it tells us that it's a good thing.
All these owners of companies or maximizing profits are shared value,
which is the same thing.
And that's helping society.
Okay,
so that's the Fisher.
That's the lesson.
A lot of that stuff is going to change a little bit,
but that's the basic idea.
So finally,
let's get to the point though,
the for 2000 years,
the public was confused about interest.
They said Aristotle,
you know,
one of the greatest geniuses of all time.
He thought interests was an unnatural act.
It was horrible.
Okay.
Even though of course,
every lots of people in Greece,
we're charging interest in the,
you know,
the,
the de Los,
the of the Delphic oracle was charging interest,
would lend money at interests and you know,
at Aristotle,
and everybody was talking about the Delphic oracle all the time.
They weren't even paying attention.
The Delphic oracle was charging interest and they were saying it's totally
unnatural.
Okay.
So,
um,
three religions all thought interest was a terrible thing.
They all thought that it was,
you know,
there should be,
the just price was,
the nominal rate of interest should be zero.
But what Fisher says is the nominal rate of interest is irrelevant.
Nobody cares about the nominal rate of interest.
They look at Apple's today and Apple's next year,
the money and stuff just gets in the way.
It's the real rate of interest that you care about.
And the real rate of interest doesn't have to be positive.
It could be negative like it is today.
But the real rate of interest,
um,
he says is the real rate of interest.
What are the determinants usually of the real rate of interest if the Federal
Reserve isn't mucking around with things,
the real rate of interest is obtained by solving for p one and p two in this
general equilibrium model.
Okay,
so what would change the real rate of interest?
All you have are the utilities and the endowments.
Okay,
so here's the economy.
What would change the real rate of interest?
So the first thing Fisher says is impatience.
So in fact is one of his most famous article is called an impatience theory of
interest.
So let's call it that.
Patients theory of interest.
So Fisher said that in his view,
people are impatient.
Why?
That means an apple today they thought was more valuable than an apple next year
because
of the poor imagination.
I was easy to think about eating the apple today.
We're going get it.
Just hold it in your hand and you're,
it's so close.
But to think about eating it in a year requires some imagination.
They had poor imagination.
And secondly,
the second main reason is they,
you know,
they mortality,
they might die between today and next year.
Okay.
So those are the two main reasons.
He gives a bunch of others,
which I'm going to mention shortly,
but these are the two most interesting ones.
Poverty of imagination and the fact that you just might die in between.
So what does it mean to say an apple next year?
It's not a sure thing.
Okay.
There's some theory of interest.
So he said that's why it makes sense to have this guy a is impatient because he
values the apple today more than a value tomorrow he's got this discount rate a
half here.
B's not impatient because the discount factor is one.
Okay.
So he put a discount factor.
Actually Fisher didn't quite have a discount faction in a more general thing.
So Sam Wilson was the one who introduced the discount factor.
Doesn't matter.
But anyway,
so it does count fact and to capture Fisher's idea that the good next year,
it's not as worth the same apple next year is not worth as much to a is an apple
this year.
Okay.
So suppose I change a half to a third,
what will happen to the real rate of interest?
So more so that makes people more impatient?
Yeah.
Why does it make them more impatient?
Because now they care even less about the good next year.
More impatient implies,
all right,
so when did this happen?
And the Reagan years,
the now generation,
everybody talked about the,
now generation people are getting more impatient.
They want,
you know,
so what happens to the wheel rate of interest when people get more impatient?
Does it go up or down?
Yup.
Okay.
So why does it go up?
That's correct.
Right.
Okay.
But now Fisher would say that a little bit more.
Fisher would say that a little bit more.
Um,
it would say a little more formally,
but that's exactly right.
So if people care,
they don't,
in order to get anybody to save because they want the stuff.
Now you're gonna have to give them a higher real rate of interest.
That's exactly right.
So how could you say it in this economy,
remembering this economy,
this Cobb Douglas economy.
You could prove it formally.
You know that if p two,
let's say equals one and we're solving for p one and here's the supply is x one,
and here's demand.
So remember x one,
you know a is going to be something like uh,
a loss.
It's p one plus p a a two times,
uh,
you know one,
oh,
sorry.
Let's make this better.
X a one equals one over one plus Delta were Delta,
what's called Delta,
the discount.
Call this delta.
Okay,
so the discount,
so right to get these,
to add up to one,
I take one plus delta.
So the weight on this thing is one over one plus Delta Times this divided by p
one.
So p one is one,
a p two was one,
okay?
Then,
uh,
this is just equal to one over one plus Delta Times ea one plus one over p two
times.
Hey,
so clearly with the same day.
So clearly the demand goes down as p one goes [inaudible].
This is a p one is p p two equals one.
So if I divide by p one p one over p one goes away and then I have p two over p
one and p two is one that's just one of p one.
So obviously as p one goes up,
your demand goes down.
That's just what you'd expect.
So p one goes up,
one goes down,
the demand goes up,
or p one goes up,
the demand goes down.
So to prove,
so that's anyway,
if you add up car Douglas people,
it always is like that.
The demand for any good goes up as the price goes down,
if its own price goes down.
So if you change Delta,
if you make Delta smaller,
that's going to raise demand for a one at the old prices.
Why?
At old equilibrium prices,
the same trick is before and old equilibrium prices.
What's going to happen?
Delta goes,
um,
down like we just said implies x a Wa x,
a one goes up.
Okay,
so there's the guys demanding more now.
Okay.
But if he's dating,
demanding more at the old equilibrium prices,
hey,
he's done.
Okay.
So the old equilibrium prices,
he's demanding more.
So the only way to clear the market as to raise p one implies p one must go up
to clear the market.
Okay,
so this is a formal proof of what he just said.
So the common sense maybe is enough for you.
If you care less about the future to get anybody to save,
you're going to have to raise the interest rate to say it formally.
If you,
we saw for equilibrium with a lower delta at the old equilibrium prices,
this guy at the old prices a wood now shift and by trying to demand more of good
one,
but if he demanded more of good one,
that would mean too much demand for good one.
And the only way to clear the price of good one is to raise the price p one.
But if he raised [inaudible] holding p two fixed,
that's just pee wanna repeat to the interest rate.
So the interest
rate has to go up.
So that's your argument made formal.
Okay,
so that's his impatience.
They rent.
That's the main determinant of interest according to Fisher.
What's the second one?
Okay,
he says,
suppose people more optimistic.
Optimistic
About,
um,
he,
I too,
everybody thinks the world is going to be much better next year.
We're going to have more endowments.
What do you think's going to happen to the interest rate?
The real interest rate.
Somebody else.
Okay.
It'll what?
Decrease.
Okay.
Why?
Save less or to save more.
Okay.
So let's think of a good acts won.
If people thought they're going to be richer at the old prices,
what would they do today for x one demand more or less today,
right?
You have the right answer is up.
He said down,
but let's just figure out why.
Okay,
so this for the reason I gave the formal argument,
as you can get confused here,
so,
uh,
let's just do the intuitive one.
So you had the idea back there,
very intuitive when he just got,
got it backwards,
but you're on the right track.
The point is,
there's going to be so much stuff around for people to eat tomorrow.
You've got to get them to want to eat all that extra stuff.
Tomorrow's,
you have to give them an incentive to want to eat all that extra stuff tomorrow.
So you have to raise the,
raise the interest rate,
not Lawrence,
he had the right idea,
the wrong conclusion.
Now how can you actually give a formal proof of that?
So you know you're not confused again,
like his question.
So he asked,
okay,
at the old prices,
what's going to happen to the demand for x one at the old prices?
Since you're going to be so rich in the future,
you think you're just incredibly rich now.
So of course you're going to consume more today.
So there's going to be more demand today and the endowment today hasn't changed.
So there's going to be more in demand today with the same endowment today.
So therefore,
uh,
in order to clear the market today,
you're going to have to raise p one relative to p two.
So the interest rate's got to go up.
Okay?
So
is that clear that it's a little surprising?
Okay.
But so let me say that again.
If you increase the endowments tomorrow,
the supply today of goods hasn't changed,
but people are Richard Tomorrow.
So clearly they're going to take,
you know,
they're going to consume this fraction of their wealth.
The wealth is up.
You tell anybody you're going to be rich,
you know,
next year you're going to be worth a fortune.
The normal person you Cobb dug us,
person's going to consume more stuff today,
anticipating is going to be so rich tomorrow he's going to borrow against
tomorrows a wealth.
And so therefore,
in order to clear today's market where the supply hasn't changed with all these
people trying to eat more today,
you have to raise today's price relative tomorrow.
That's raised the real interest rate.
Okay,
so what's a third example?
Suppose,
uh,
this is the fissures.
Most famous one.
Suppose you transfer money,
transfer wealth from poor to rich.
What would happen?
Okay,
we have to make an extra assumption here.
Fisher felt that the people who were rich were rich because they were patient.
Okay?
They could charge interest and get lots of money.
So if you change,
if you change,
well,
if you take away some money from the poor,
that's what's happened in the American economy over the last,
uh,
you know,
15 or 20 years,
the rich have gotten richer and the poor are pretty much back where they were
before.
So suppose the rich get rich at the expense of the poor.
What's going to that due to the real rate of interest?
Okay,
I'll hang on a second.
He,
Yup.
That's gonna lower it.
Why is that?
Okay.
So you,
there's an intuitive way of saying it,
which is his,
which is that the,
uh,
the rich because their patient are probably the lenders now they're even more
willing to lend.
And so the interest rate has to,
uh,
go down to get to these other people to borrow.
Okay.
Or a formal way of saying it is that if you transfer money from the rich to the
poor,
okay.
That means the poor guys because they've,
so the wealth,
th th the,
the rich guys always consume a higher proportion in the future because they're
more patients.
So more patient guy will consume more in the future.
So if you take away wealth from an,
from an impatient guy and give it to a patient guy,
you're going to increase.
Um,
the,
uh,
you're going to make more.
The economy is going to be more in the hands of the patient people.
And so the patient people,
the,
you know,
the mix is going to change.
People on average are more patient than they were before.
So on average in the economy that are going to be consumed less than they were
before of today's goods.
And so the shift is going to be in this direction,
right?
Cause you've taken,
you've made people,
a lot of them inpatient,
a lot of patient,
you've increased the patient ones and increase the impatient ones.
So on balance,
you're going to increase,
you're going to decrease demand today because it was the inpatient ones who
wanted to eat today and the other guys were willing to wait.
Now,
now the guys who are willing to wait,
these guys don't have any money.
They're the ones doing all the consuming today and now they're not.
They don't,
can't afford to it much consuming.
So you're going to reduce consumption today.
So to get the market to clear again,
you have to lower the interest rate this time.
Okay.
So those are three famous conclusions of Fisher.
More impatient people,
higher interest rate,
more optimistic about the future.
Higher interest rate.
Yeah.
Transfers from the poor to the rich.
Lower interest rate.
Okay.
So what happens to the stock market in this case?
Suppose people are more impatient.
Does the stock market go up or down?
Yeah,
down because the stock market price is just this,
the real interest rate times the dividends.
So I haven't told you the dividends changed.
So if the dividends are the same and they real interest rates gone up,
the stock market's gone down.
So what happens if,
uh,
oh impatience.
Suppose people more optimistic about the future.
So not about the stocks producing more a bit about whether there's more stuff in
the world.
You know,
they're an own endowments will be bigger.
Okay.
The stock market's going to go down.
That one's a little subtler because they could be,
they could be optimistic about the stock prices,
about the stocks producing more.
So that's ambiguous.
So let's do the third.
Suppose you transfer wealth from the poor to the rich.
What's going to happen to the stock market?
It's going to go up.
So what happened in the last 20 years?
The rich got richer.
The poor God poor.
The interest rates got lower and lower in the stock market got higher and Higher
Justice Fisher would have said,
okay,
so I want to now and with just Fisher and Shakespeare.
So I'm going to go over just a couple minutes.
Um,
okay.
So,
okay,
maybe I'll have to start with Shakespeare.
Okay.
So Fisher's theory of interests,
as I said was,
was uh,
you know,
making sense of thousands of years of confusion.
So the,
the idea is that,
yeah,
interest is nothing other than you shouldn't think of nominal interest.
People look through all that.
They look at the real rate of interest and the real rate of interest is just the
ratio of two prices,
just like everything else.
And Eq Librium.
So therefore there is no such thing as,
it's an important price.
Okay.
Like anything else,
but I've maybe I forgot to say it.
There's no such thing as adjust price.
The price in fact,
that equilibrium fines is the best price because that's the price that's gonna,
that's gonna lead new firms and inventors to use technologies that help the
economies opposed to hurting the economy and wasting resources.
So the price that the market finds is the just price and the real rate of
interest is the right wheel of rate of interest provided that people are
rational and see through this veil.
So why is it that the real rate of interest is typically positive?
Well,
it's because as I said,
you know,
people are,
uh,
and there are these different reasons.
Okay.
Now,
Fisher said one other reason that screws up the real rate of interest is people
sometimes get confused by inflation.
So this is an aside,
he said that all contracts should be inflation indexed and he forced his Yale
Secretary and his secretary,
his at his company to sign to change their contracts to get,
I guess as Gail second was probably wrong,
the secretaries that is as,
as business Remington,
he forced them to accept deals where they're,
their wage was indexed to inflation.
And of course the great depression happened and all the prices collapsed and
these all the secretaries got less money out of the deal.
So they go if he wasn't too popular with them either.
But anyway,
so,
um,
okay.
He says impatience is a fundamental attribute of human nature.
Okay.
As long as people like things today rather than tomorrow,
there's going to be interest.
So impatience,
interest is,
as it were,
inpatients crystallized into a market rate.
Okay.
And the reasons for inpatients or this foresight,
lack of foresight,
expectation,
you know,
possibility of dying.
And then he talks about self control and stuff like that.
The greater the foresight.
Okay.
Et cetera.
And now he,
now he has this racist view of the world,
which I think is worth mentioning.
So he compares the Scotch and the Irish.
Okay.
So the Scotch or patient,
the Irish are totally impatient.
Okay.
And then he no self control and it gets worse and worse.
Um,
I can show you all of this.
Okay.
So Holland,
Scotland,
England,
France,
you know,
these are all the places like his family was probably from their incredibly
patient.
They're wonderful.
They've got low rates of interest,
incredibly thrifty people.
Then you look at all these other dreadful people,
Chinese Indians,
blacks,
Java,
southerners,
you know,
American Indians and then Greeks and Italians,
he mentioned later hopeless high rates of interest in Greg will be impatient.
So,
uh,
anyway,
the,
the patient accumulate wealth and by waiting and lending they make production
possible because the people with all the good ideas,
where are they going to get the money to produce?
They're going to get it out of the patient.
People are willing to wait.
Okay.
Now if you could wait,
can shy talk for five more minutes or do you need to go?
I was going to do my,
maybe I should let you go anyway.
So what I was going to say last,
I won't say it,
is that Shakespeare anticipated all of fishers,
impatience,
theory of interest,
and when a step further he said,
well,
that's great,
but you should take into account that people won't keep their promises,
and if they don't keep their promises,
you need collateral.
And if we need collateral,
that's going to change a lot of stuff.
And Fisher and Shakespeare,
I already had a lot of that figured out.
Most of this course is going to be about,
which I believe it or not,
what Shakespeare had to say about the rate of interest in collateral.
Okay,
next,
next time.